if you're breathing through your mouth
when you're sleeping
what can happen is because you're you're
through the neurology of sleep your
central nervous system innervates your
muscles and your tongue is a major
muscle and so when you're in rem sleep
in particular your tongue can become
temporarily paralyzed it sounds a little
weird but if you're breathing through
your mouth and you're laying back you
can envision if your tongue is not
getting any sort of tonic nervous system
input it can collapse your airway and
this is very common
way more common than people realize like
sleep disorder breathing is a spectrum
people you have normal you know nasal
breathing then on the other end of the
spectrum you have uh sleep apnea most of
us are kind of in the middle where we
have these periodic apnic events one
clue of people who have this is they
wake up in the middle of night to go pee
because when you're having this sort of
choking yourself on your own tongue
which is crazy a lot of people do this
um it affects vasopressin and the
retention of water it can cause you to
go peace
welcome to the pretty intense podcast uh
today is going to be an education in
health and wellness when it comes to
working out supplements food fasting
exercise blood sugar insulin all those
things and it is with mike mutzel he has
a degree in biology he has a master's in
clinical nutrition and he's also an
author with a couple of books he is
really just a wealth of information um
so i mentioned some of those things that
we talked about and all we did was go
into depth about them and so it's
fascinating to hear from you know a
scientific perspective how the body
reacts to stress reacts to fasting
reacts to regular routines and not
shaking things up and then we hit you
with a good one at the end with how to
lose weight really fast so i hope that
you enjoy this episode it's one of those
note-taking kind of episodes but be sure
to check him out mike has tons of
information he's making videos all the
time he has a great youtube channel uh
also click the subscribe and hit the
thumbs up if you like this enjoy this
episode i recognize that i recognize the
shot from all of your videos yep this is
where it goes down yeah yeah is it an
office or is it like uh have you just uh
taken up the living room or something
it's an office yeah um but my daughter's
room is just right next door so when
friends are over it's kind of chaotic
but we do what we can right with the
home office oh totally i where are you
anyway
yeah seattle area
kirkland washington specifically well
how do you how do you deal with the lack
of sunlight then
it's tough you have to be very
intentional about it right um so i built
a sauna so we're doing the sauna
and try to travel my mom's in the bay
area so i'll go down to california or
take an la trip or something like that
but you have to be very intentional
about it yeah
so i'm curious what your day's been like
so far
like what have you done tell me all of
your all of your things that you do
yeah great question
um so for me like morning sunlight is
really important so first thing in the
morning
before i even get on my phone and check
you know
things out whether it's internet
accounts stocks all that sort of stuff
just get outside get some movement so i
do some breath work and i faced east and
i really just try to get you know sun in
my eyes and get the dogs out for a walk
then i come back and do a little
meditation 10 to 15 minutes after i've
done the breath work
i don't know if you've dabbled into
meditation at all but you know the the
whole mindfulness meditation community
doesn't really acknowledge the
importance of breath work and
you know that hyperventilation followed
by retention sort of this box breathing
where you inhale and then you pause and
then you exhale you hold and then repeat
um that can be really helpful to get
what is your exact breathing that you do
well so my first set of breasts this is
more like i learned this from this book
uh about a decade ago um but this is
more of just a quick to expand the rib
cage so it's can kind of for people
watching so it's really sort of more
aggressive but you inhale really
aggressively
like that and you're using your arms to
sort of move your rib cage and diaphragm
so it just helps sort of expand breathe
going up and then you exhale the arms
down
arms down and try to be sort of as
intense as you can and especially on the
exhale it's much easier for people to
take a deep breath but really when you
exhale focus on that lower part of that
deep part of your lung and just like ah
like get it all out and then rapidly
inhale again so i'll do like 15 sets of
i'm sorry 15 reps it would be one set
then i hold
and then it's you're pretty you can be a
little light-headed depending upon how
intense you go i'll do two sets of that
um but that's just a great way to sort
of prime the lungs move the body move
your arms and again you're facing yeast
you're getting the sun in your eyes
which is great for your circadian clock
system and all that yeah that that's
that's not it though we're at least at
this point in time it's uh we're
afternoon now so i should there should
be is what else there's more yeah sorry
is this too slow of the detail i don't
mean to no you're doing great i'm
actually asking for more
yeah okay so that's your morning that so
that's the morning and then i'll have
coffee after i do all that so the idea
is to sort of get sunlight get some
movement get some some air calm the mind
focus uh with meditation and then i'll
do a little bit of work i like to you
know with creative work with reading i
was reading an article today from this
plus one journal of biology talking
about light exposure and this expert
consensus was saying you know what light
should really be viewed as problematic
as junk food or as problematic as say
environmental toxins because our
photoreceptors in our retina are are
transmitting all these external cues
about daylight
about light exposure during the day and
also artificial light at night and
that's really augmenting this intricate
circuiting clock system that we have
that
affects hormones that affects
detoxification pathways that impacts
neurotransmitter synthesis so you know
so many of us are focused on the foods
that we eat
exercise and all that is good but we
really should be as vigilant about
minimizing exposure to artificial light
in the three hours before bedtime and
being more intentional about like as we
film this about one o'clock
great time to get outside and go for a
walk and a lot of us
you know i see you're in your home i'm
in my home the the lux the intensity of
the light in the home is just a fraction
of what the sun is offering and so as
humans we evolve to be out in that
whether it's farming or agriculture or
hunting or just being outdoors and we're
not getting that so so many people you
know wonder why they can't fall asleep
at night and wonder why their hormones
are off or they're getting into
menopause early or all these things and
it's it's intimately linked to the
circadian clock system so
yeah that paper was just phenomenal yeah
okay well you touched on it just for a
second you said the word which is
something that i just love so much
and
if there's anything bad about it i'm
just gonna have to chalk it up like i'm
willing to do
really about anything except for in this
one specific area to be more healthy to
have more longevity to
optimize my hormones optimize
energy
but when it comes to coffee i gotta have
coffee
um i went without coffee last year for
about two and a half months i just
stopped and i had no problem i didn't
have a single headache from it i wasn't
less energetic i just love coffee and so
tell me the the good and the bad and
what is sort of like the optimal way to
consume it and i'm sure i'm gonna have
more questions about it but let's just
start there
yeah you know i don't think coffee is as
bad as some people present it to be um
the coffee that i think it's really the
timing of the coffee consumption so for
example um we're recording this at at
one o'clock pacific standard time i
would definitely not advise you have
coffee after this point in the day um
now if you're gonna go do a hard workout
if you're like oh my gosh i haven't seen
my girlfriends in like three months
we're gonna go out tonight find a little
caffeine but caffeine really is
problematic for
um helping you fall asleep it it you
know disturbs um all the adenosine
metabolism in the brain so it's going to
augment sleep and so that's not good but
i'm a fan especially you know we were
talking before we started recording
about maybe a wedding's coming up losing
a little weight you know a lot of people
have you know these want to get in shape
for summer using caffeine before you
exercise has been shown to prevent the
catabolism or the breakdown of muscle
which is a good thing
and enhance the oxidation of fat so
in the morning i'm a big fan of that and
that's i do
a double espresso and
when when choosing the beans i'm a
bigger fan of an organic light roast
and there's a few different reasons for
that but that's what i preferentially
choose
i periodically will have just say usp
caffeine in the form of like a
pre-workout but i try to use that
sparingly that's sort of like oh my gosh
you know i'm doing something extra
intense today or something's going on
where i need a little but i really
advise people not be dependent upon
pre-workouts and straight up caffeine
and use use coffee
as a little a little tool but where
people get into problems with coffee is
they have the coffee then they have the
the stevia packets or they have splenda
where they have a bunch of sugar
and it becomes basically a four or five
six hundred calorie energy bomb which
that can add up you know you add in
three meals there plus some wine plus
some beer you're looking at three to
four thousand calories and unless you're
really active you're probably going to
gain some weight so those are my
thoughts on coffee well i drink it black
total purist
um
so you talked about the timing and this
is because i've read a lot and watched a
lot of videos about coffee and timing
and sunlight and you know
that there that your body um has sort of
the natural energy from
waking up and is that cortisol that
produces that and kind of gives you a
burst and that it really you should wait
at least an hour perhaps after you wake
up to drink it
me i i wake up i force myself to drink a
glass of water
and i actually put right now i put um
some aloe vera water aloe vera in it and
then um i put a little bit of lemon
juice
and some apple cider vinegar just just a
little bit and so i force myself i drink
that or just regular water
but then i'm ready for coffee
and that might only be like 30 40
minutes after i wake up maybe
you know i think that's fine i know a
lot of people do split hairs on having
to wait this amount of time in this
you know some days that's not practical
i mean if you're going off to travel or
you're doing something um but if it make
my my my thing is like if it makes you
feel good and it's you know there's not
a lot of downside so you're like okay if
you only wait 45 minutes what's the
worst that's going to happen your
cortisol awakening in response which is
theoretically why people are saying
delay the onset of coffee should already
be kicking in even before you wake up
that should be sort of waking wait
awakening you so i don't worry about
that there's other things that i worry
about i would you know and if we're too
regimented this is another thing if
we're if we exert too much willpower i'm
only going to consume this much coffee
i'm going to meditate i got to exercise
i can't have sugar i can't do this then
by the time it's 10 o'clock you're like
oh my gosh forget it i need that glass
of wine or i need some ice cream so we
need to be mindful about how much
willpower were and how much restraint
we're sort of inserting into our day um
and so i think you know having a little
coffee not a big deal if it's within a
half an hour 40 minutes awakening sure
sure
um this is a a little bit of a side
question to the coffee but sort of in in
light of getting sunlight in the morning
i have a big you know juve like six
panel red light and um
and i think i kind of know the answer
but i'm curious from a scientific
standpoint
sometimes i think to myself oh man
especially right now in arizona it's
like sunny at 5 00 a.m
it's getting sunny and i know that
because that's when i wake up because i
wake up with the light
and i think well should i do the red
light because normally my routine would
be to get up have that water a little
bit of coffee red light stretch a little
bit of yoga during that dry brush cold
shower get some clothes on go walk the
dogs that's kind of my normal routine
but i'm like man
i probably should just skip the red
light and just get outside like it's
it's like
is that accurate or is there some
benefit with red light specifically
is there
more
density of those wavelengths that it's
giving you that helps with the
mitochondria and other kinds of things
that it's meant to improve or should you
just get outside
it's a great question i think this time
of year you should just get outside yeah
um especially for you it's starting to
get warmer and warmer and then you may
not be outside in the middle part of the
day so i think that's more important um
there are definitely some mitochondrial
benefits with regards to and i we too
have the six panel juve and it's an
awesome great setup right um but i i
consider that more therapeutic in the
wintertime specifically you mentioned
how the heck do you survive in seattle
like that is because sometimes it
doesn't get light out until 8 30 you
know um like
and that's really tough so that's where
i think the juve comes in and also it
can help with an injury let's say for
example you're like well i have a bicep
injury or
you know was training had some
challenges um
i know you recently got into a a an
accident right there was a spinning
situation going on so maybe that could
help with the recovery then you go
outside but but i think if you're gonna
you know
i would definitely prefer the sun over
the juve as much as i love the juve
i have a lot of questions about fasting
but first i want to start off with just
being a fat burner versus a sugar burner
and
i get that you know once you become more
metabolically flexible you should be
able to kind of tap into either and then
perhaps you're not as hungry as often
because your body is adapted and it can
shift sort of
energy mechanisms but how the hell do
you know if you're burning fat or sugar
because i get hungry and i try i mean i
try minimum of 12 hours um and then
sometimes you know a little bit more
depending on the situation or the
um the time of the month but um but how
do we know when we're burning fat versus
sugar
the really practical way to do this is
actually to test and you can get a
glucometer and i encourage all my
clients to do this is just go down to
walgreens or rite aid or your closest
drug store people think oh a glucose
meter that's only for diabetics no this
is for everyone we need to know
how our body is processing the foods
that we eat and we need to know how our
lifestyle is impacting the post meal
processing so
you mentioned like even if you eat a low
carb diet
for example but most people in the post
meal window their blood sugar is going
to go up so you're naturally going to
sort of
oxidize or burn more glucose in the post
meal window but most americans
unfortunately stay in that state because
not only are they eating foods that
dramatically increase the glucose but
they're snacking every two to three
hours or more and so the glucose is
they're always sort of oxidizing or
burning glucose and never get to the
point to where
maybe your eye would be in because we
exercise and because we compress that
feeding window aka we fast we get to the
point where the glucose goes down
and the body needs energy and it starts
to dip into the fat stores and we can
talk about hormonally why that happens
but to specifically again address the
question how do you know you would get a
glucose meter you would start to test
your glucose and about you could do like
30 minutes after it's just a little
finger prick 29 gauge it stings a little
bit but it's no big deal so you could
test your glucose again 30 minutes after
a meal 60 minutes after the meal in 90
minutes and you should see that glucose
starting to come down and that would
indicate that as glucose comes down then
you start you should start to oxidize
fats for fuel uh in the post meal window
oh well i
wore a continuous blood glucose monitor
last year for a few weeks and i mean i
recommend it to anyone because it's such
good information not only do you um
yeah i mean you realize that that little
bit of snacking it can be a bite or two
of something and you're like oh my gosh
i've just ruined my flatline beautiful
no blood sugar spike situation i have
going on but also of course learning
about what foods um your body uh does
well with blood sugar-wise and which
ones you don't like for instance just as
an example i do terrible with sweet
potatoes and oats they were like through
the moon um but then i did fine with uh
popcorn uh like corn tortilla chips i
tried rice not too bad um so anyway it
was very good information but
so
it's that simple so you're saying that
as soon as the blood sugar comes down
that it's at its normal amount which
would be i don't know 70 or something
like that ish
yeah it's probably a little different
for everybody but that indicates that
you're in
in a fat burning mode
that you're that you would be oxidizing
more fats for fuel as a proportion
because you need to either so the brain
is either going to be oxidizing glucose
or fats or ketones and so when glucose
is low
that's going to approximate or suggest
that your body is basically in a in a
metabolic state such that fat is being
broken down and is being directly
utilized in the form of free fatty acids
or your brain is utilizing ketones that
are also
a
formed as a consequence of fat oxidation
so another thing that you can do look at
is breath acetone so there's a meter
called the biosens meter and i i like
this because um it's a it's a way to
sort of
your body off gasses acetone when you're
in a state of ketosis and when you're in
a state of ketosis the sort of
prerequisite for that is low glucose low
insulin so again insulin is a hormone
that takes glucose out of the
bloodstream and puts it into either your
fat tissue or your muscle
so
when those two situations are low and
then another hormone that is also
released from the pancreas i.e like
insulin as well called glucagon glucagon
actually helps burn fat as well so low
glucose low insulin high glucagon the
hormonal sort of signature that's going
to help you burn fat
and anyway when that is happening your
your breath acetone starts to increase
so that's another way that people can
it's an at-home thing very easy to do i
think it's 189 some odd dollars you blow
into it and it will tell you
where your levels are so that's that's
another tool and that's where i think
it's helpful like you mentioned the
continuous glucose monitor phenomenal i
have a few questions for you on that uh
but but the breath acetone is cool
because it some people are like well
i've heard that this guru says i should
fast for 20 hours a day no i should fast
for 12 hours and then you can sort of
bio individualize you know your own
fasting protocol you know not everyone
is going to benefit or you know if
you're really physically active and
you're training a lot do you really need
to fast for 22 hours out of a 24 hour
day no like you're probably okay doing a
12 to 14 hour time restricted feeding
window but if you're morbidly obese you
don't exercise you've been living off
processed you know junk food yeah maybe
a one meal a day for you or a an 18-hour
fast could accelerate your sort of
metabolic healing processes so
um again that's where these tools can
come in and they're just they're just
one piece of the puzzle that can help us
triangulate and better understand
but but i think it's also helpful not
just and my question for you
this is not just about nutrition but
also the lifestyle factor so for me
danica i found when i wore the
continuous glucose monitor
i hate waiting in lines especially like
tsa lines and i i was in a canadian
airport and i'm normally tsa pre and
flight clear so
i'm not used to like waiting 90 minutes
in line you know for the x-ray and i was
about to miss my flight and my glucose
went from 70 fasted up to 170. so i was
wondering
you mentioned you know sweet potatoes
and things like that and oats were
problematic but did you notice sleep or
stress impacted your glucose yep at one
point in time i was having a heated
conversation and i looked at it and i
was like holy [ __ ]
my blood sugar spiked because i was
heated also with exercise
that also
spiked my blood sugar
so i'm kind of curious about that i'm
actually what i want to start get into
is a little bit of sort of like the
stresses of the body versus with with
all the kind of with with not with
fasting with exercise and those kinds of
things but i totally noticed that the
times where i was consuming no food at
all
um that i had stress or i was working
out and exercising more with more
intensity
would definitely spike my blood sugar
okay so i think those situations are
helpful to unpack for people because
they assume
high blood sugar bad but we know with
exercise um you know the hormones the
adrenaline the noradrenaline that help
us actually have a good workout and also
help us burn fat those increase glucose
and so we need to understand that if you
were exercising
if you're running an ultra you know
you're running 100 miles in a day
every single day that much that high
glucose from exercise would be
considered problematic but because we're
exercising for say 30 or 40 minutes a
day we're having a transient increase
and then it really drops down yeah and
part of that increase in in glucose is
because you're liberating stored glucose
known as glycogen
and once you deplete that glycogen
that's a really powerful signal to
actually start to oxidize and burn more
fat in the post-exercise window so
for folks listening don't be scared of
exercise induced increases in glucose
not problematic right it's totally
different from
food-induced increases in glucose like
having a slurpee having the glucose flux
from a slurpy is not the same as having
glucose fluxes from exercise so when we
deplete that glycogen when we burn
through that blood sugar from our
workout
our body thinks oh my gosh we have to
re-prioritize
re-synthesizing that muscle glycogen so
while we're doing that we're actually
going to pivot into a fat burning state
and this is why short duration high
intensity interval training although it
doesn't directly oxidize or burn fat
during the workout session in the post
exercise window it just a short duration
20 30 minutes of hit training ox
increases fatty acid oxidation for up to
36 hours depending upon how intense it
is in contrast that same sort of
duration of exercise doing continuous
cardio it burns significantly more fat
during the actual exercise session
but that's it there's not a lot of post
exercise fat oxidation so
really important that we're not scared
of
intense exercise because it does
increase glucose now
that's the exercise element but the
stress aspect really important because
you mentioned you had a heated
conversation glucose went up well for
some people they're having those heated
conversations or having that physiologic
stress exactly all the time maybe
they're in customer service maybe
they drive a taxi in new york city uh
maybe they're in a terrible relationship
or marriage and so it's like going home
is stressful right so there's this
difference between acute stress from say
exercise or what have you and this
chronic psychological stress that
manifests physiologically
that is really problematic and
not health not not health promoting
whatsoever because when your glucose is
doing this all day that's going to
trigger you to then reach for the candy
bar or the ice cream
or binge watch netflix or whatever and
that's where
uh you know sort of the non-nutritional
factors i.e stress perceived stress and
all that can can cause your diet to go
awry and so it's really important that
we're aware of this and again that's why
testing can be helpful
especially notice that of course after
you eat if you just if i just went for a
walk for 10 minutes
it would totally blunt the blood sugar
response you don't have to do much i
could even just like do dishes and
vacuum or something like i i just have
to get up and move and walk and take
steps and and it was amazing how it
would reduce it but um but as far as
exercise goes um
walking would would definitely like
reduce blood sugar no matter what it
would stabilize it it just there was so
many positive things about walking and
the fact that you can do as much of it
as you want humanly really um and i was
very curious about that so if we plug
that into the morning now and i'm going
to kind of feed maybe some stressors in
that i have questions about but
such as this morning i was like you know
i'm going to go for a walk and then i'm
going to come back and it was actually
because i'd listen to something you said
you like do your walk and your little
bit of movement in the morning and then
lift in the afternoon and
so i was like i'll just walk and then i
came back and had breakfast and i did a
couple little things and then i did a
little just interval session of like 30
minutes of just 10 different moves over
and over again
and um and and that that felt really
good i've always actually felt really
good to eat before i work out um so
is it better in the morning to
uh to
because i know there's also some science
behind
lifting and exercise before you eat and
it can perhaps boost your
fat burning
pathways to
to tap into that fat storage while
you're still in a fasted state so
and i know nothing is black and white
but
you know from your perspective what's
the what's the what's the science behind
all that and what's the right thing to
do
yeah this is a great question you know
the research is a little mixed on this
um you know bodybuilders that's just if
we look at what what actual real people
do because the science is a little mixed
what physically fit people do when
they're training for a competition to
get as lean as possible they generally
do
fasted cardio um in the morning to
accelerate fat loss but the research is
a little mixed on that what what i
suggest cardio just be clear like
walking running you're doing steady
state yeah the fit the bodybuilding
community is all about sort of steady
state cardio 45 minutes of running or
walking
usually walking on a treadmill or doing
a stair stepper um there might be some
incremental added fat loss from that but
i generally recommend if people are
honest with their own metabolic health
if they're morbidly obese or overweight
have a lot of weight to lose the
argument to do fasted exercise is more
favorable but someone like yourself
already physically fit you're probably
trying to just maintain the muscle you
have gain some strength you know you
don't need to lose 100 pounds i think
it's great to actually have a meal
beforehand just a small amount of food
because you will have a better workout
and so that's where
if as long as you're putting that
intensity in
i will uh
having enter you know the incremental
increase in fat oxidation i think is not
worth the loss of intensity that you can
have through that exercise if you are
having a little bit of food beforehand
so that's what i suggest with that the
other thing too is if we dig too much of
an energetic hole when we're working out
let's say we're fasted then we crush a
workout and like yeah we can have and
women are actually more susceptible to
this than men a post exercise sort of
binge so
if we say we burn 600 calories or 900
calories during that exercise session
maybe we do crossfit we do intervals we
have our friends there we have caffeine
we're super pumped up afterwards we can
feel like we deserve more calories than
we actually burned and it can sort of
work against us so i think this is where
the individual needs to come you know if
you're prone to overeating in general
then don't work out fasted because it's
probably going to cause you to overeat
in the post-exercise window
and if you're already used to training
and you know what you're doing and
you're you know you have a routine then
have a little food beforehand you're
probably going to have a better workout
but if you're a novice you're kind of
going anyway you're not really working
out that intensely totally fine doing
that fasted and then you could eat
afterwards um
so different options for different folks
okay
what about the effects of the stress of
fasting the stress of exercise
on the body in particular perhaps the
adrenal
adrenal support in the body
i really grapple with that because
i in the past year have done a lot of
testing and i know that my
cortisol was spiking in the middle of
the night based on the dutch test
which is a test where you
pee on a piece of paper like four to
five times a day and
since i go to the bathroom in the middle
of the night i got the middle of the
night one which made it five and my
cortisol was spiking then and actually
tapering from there and never rising
when i got up
um and so
uh it would indicate adrenal fatigue to
some i would maybe um and so i really
wonder you know for for people who
maybe have had a stressful life or bends
through stressful things whether it's
work or relationships or
um or perhaps even just like a bunch of
hard workouts or something like that
what's you know where what's the sweet
spot and is it better to take care of
yourself and go for the walk or is it is
it still better to use the fat burning
potential of
exercising and fasting because that's
the other thing is just the amount of
fasting
is another stress around the body so
where's the happy medium with all that i
don't i don't have the answer for
everyone but we do know of course that
that we need to look have a realistic
evaluation
at our stress life load bucket you know
and so if we're doing super intense
short duration high intensity interval a
lot of volume in particular
paired with under eating paired with
life load
problematic and so i think we can i know
we can dig ourselves into a whole i've
done it before
and so if we start to stand up too
quickly we get lightheaded we get dizzy
those are signs and symptoms that
something you're starting to feel burnt
out right you're waking up lethargic all
those things but but i will say you know
fasting
it does increase cortisol and
noradrenaline but so does eating food
like there's a lot so does waking up in
the morning so there are other things
that increase that so i think because
you know we we know that fasting does
increase these sort of what are called
counter regulatory hormones cortisol
adrenaline or adrenaline it doesn't mean
that it's always bad and in some
contexts fasting can actually
increase heart rate variability which is
a sign of your sort of parasympathetic
branch of your autonomic nervous system
so
you know there's there's a lot to this
and this is why i you know if we sort of
just pause and take a small little side
step to talk about the whole circadian
clock system and circadian rhythms
anyone who has adrenal fatigue or a sort
of blunted cortisol awakening response
that you discover through the dutch test
this is where we need to be extra
mindful about artificial light exposure
at night and how much daylight we're
getting and being so intentional uh
anyone with adrenal fatigue should be
taken they're eating lunch outside
should be really on it with that morning
walk and and literally like in the three
hours before bedtime no electronics or
very low intensity electronics and not a
lot of halogen or led fluorescent lights
in their in in screens and so forth
because
that is way worse for the adrenals in
the circadian clock system then a little
exercise so even television at night
this is the thing the tv is so it's
really the intensity and how close it is
to the phone is here right
so intense he's out here so
but it's also much bigger so
is it mean every technical device or
and are you okay with the glasses like i
have some
you know uh blue light glasses um
does that do it will that fix it or is
it just
really purely especially if you're
dealing with this fatigue
just got to read a book or something
yeah or
do it earlier like like maybe you watch
your television earlier then you can go
for a walk or something
within the 90 minutes before bed i would
say no tv especially if you're dealing
with adrenal issues and trying to
correct things
perimenopausal postmenopausal women
really important
because that change that transition um
the the estrogen influences the
circadian clock system and so there's a
loss of rhythmicity so that's why you
see women sort of waking up sometimes at
three in the morning or what have you
just took over me though just to go to
the bathroom i go right yeah yeah is
that is that but that is is that an
indicator
no no so but when you get up to go the
bathroom you would definitely want to
use
i don't gosh it's in my bedroom so i
don't have it right here but a little
headlamp so you're not turning all the
lights sure yeah i know i walk i
i have
basically my uh rail yeah yeah exactly
and um my
sort of muscle memory for the steps is
pretty good
there you go that's good yeah so when
you start turning on all the lights then
your brain is saying in your eyes the
photoreceptors are like oh yeah it's we
should get up now and then people can't
fall asleep um i can't sleep if i don't
go to the bathroom i took me a while to
learn that but if i was kind of restless
i really in the middle of the night when
it was still dark i and i even if i
didn't feel it strongly
i would sort of not be able to get back
to sleep and as soon as i just went to
the bathroom i would go right right back
to sleep so i actually it actually helps
me go back to sleep
that's good but i drink too much water
especially at night i know that's the
problem right drinking water earlier so
another small side step because you
brought it up
do you have you heard of mouth taping
and nose breathing and mouth have i
haven't read the book breathe but isn't
that kind of sort of what they talk
about and there's actually specific
mouth tape
yeah yeah so the mouth tape so if you're
breathing through your mouth when you're
sleeping what can happen is because
you're you're through the neurology of
sleep your central nervous system
innervates your muscles and your tongue
is a major muscle and so when you're in
rem sleep in particular your tongue can
become temporarily paralyzed it sounds a
little weird but if you're breathing
through your mouth and you're laying
back you can envision if your tongue is
not getting any sort of tonic nervous
system input it can collapse your airway
and this is very common way more common
than people realize like sleep disorder
breathing is a spectrum people you have
normal you know nasal breathing then on
the other end of the spectrum you have
uh sleep apnea most of us are kind of in
the middle where we have these periodic
apnic events uh and it's called sleep
disorder breathing so
one of one clue of people who have this
is they wake up in the middle of night
to go pee because when you're having
this sort of temporarily parallel you
know choking yourself on your own tongue
which is crazy a lot of people do this
um it affects vasopressin and the
retention of water and so it can cause
you to go pee so that's a sim i'm not
saying get your mouth free
the specific tape is called three the
company 3m the 3m micropore tape i
encourage people to just experiment with
this it can be a game changer for sleep
and you mentioned the cortisol awakening
response so what you what i encourage my
clients to do is before putting on
before bed you can maybe take it out in
the evening put some tape on when you're
reading a book or doing something else
and get comfortable breathing through
your nose and so on um and yeah that's
how we should be breathing when we're
sleeping is through our nose and the
tape can just help facilitate that got
it i am i'm friends with um gab gabby um
and laird uh laird hamilton gaby reese
and she would sometimes uh have us
because she would lead some workouts and
um she would say okay go on the rower
row 5000 but breathe out of your nose
only and i was like oh man it's crazy
with how much different it is to breathe
just through your nose especially when
you're doing activity but that's a great
tip for at night what are some things
that people can do because i mean i
wonder about this for myself
how do we know if we're
in adrenal fatigue how do we know if
we're uh our cortisol is because i was
here too there's also the other side of
it where your cortisol is through the
roof and so what are what are your
recommended tests to see if peop if
because of somebody suspicious
of
where they're at um biologically because
we also all think oh we're fine but even
a heated conversation raises your blood
sugar so what do you recommend for
people
yeah well the test that you recommended
the dutch test i i do quite like that
because it does look at the
sort of the the rhythmicity of your
hormones and the metabolites throughout
the day so you'll see the cortisol
awakening response the time then you
also can look at dhea and that's
something we can take a deeper dive into
but
um but so that's like an objective way
to sort of quantify hey how are my
adrenal glands doing if people just want
to ask themselves you know sort of
subjectively you know the big things are
how do you feel when you wake up in the
morning i.e are you ready to go hit the
day are you excited do you have energy
or are you like oh my gosh i can barely
get out of bed i'm exhausted i'm tanked
um i'm lethargic i'm like have no energy
to work out i get dizzy when i stand up
um very sensitive to sunlight that's
another thing as well
um and then also if your rhythm's all
sort of messed up then some people can
be sort of tired but wired when they
should be ready to go to bed so some
people their adrenals start to really
kick in because of circadian clock
disruption later in the day and so your
cortisol should be at its lowest point
around bedtime
but for some people it's starting to get
high and that's why they're like dude
i'm like i have so much energy now that
so i'm gonna binge watch netflix and
this and then fall asleep at four in the
morning and it just creates this really
not so good cycle so
you know there's some sort of
controversy in in the whole health
community really what is adrenal fatigue
is it just circadian rhythm disruption
because again
you should have a strong cortisol
awakening response but so many people
now are exposed to artificial light we
have leds in in compact fluorescence we
have televisions we have screens and so
that could that's enough light to pivot
the entire circadian clock system to
trigger your adrenals to start making
cortisol when it really should not be so
there's that element of it but then
there's also the life load aspect the
psychological stressors and all that so
what do we do about it i'm a big fan of
dhea so this is a hormone that a lot of
people aren't really familiar with but
it's a mother hormone that feeds into
estrogen and testosterone and the
adrenal glands we've all heard of
andropause and we see all these hrt
clinics everywhere hormone replacement
therapy clinics are it's on the radio
and so we've heard of menopause which is
where women stop making you know
reproductive hormones and so forth but
we have adrenopause your adrenals
naturally in some people can go through
a state of sort of uh can take a little
hiatus and so that one of the hormones
that really can decline as you age is
called dhea
and you can test for this again the
dutch test looks at it but if you just
get blood work from your primary care
doctor or a functional medicine doctor
dha sulfate is what you'd look for
i'm seeing this people that i work with
in their 20s it's very low
and so when dhea is low then their
testosterone is going to be low then
their estrogens are going to be low and
this can be very problematic so um
yeah i i honestly i think it's a
combination the circadian rhythm
disruptions the psychological stressors
and all that but in your case
because and i don't know how recent the
dutch test was and i would want to look
at your other hormones but i might
suggest considering taking like 5
milligrams or maybe 10 milligrams of
dhea
around 8 pm at night do you take dha i
do yeah yeah part of the testing my
testosterone was low dha low um estrogen
project all my hormones were low we can
get into that but it's not necessarily
super important um but uh but yeah all
my hormones were low and so the dhea was
to uh with the functional doctor i was
working with at the time was to help
with um boosting testosterone
um
so yeah i mean i take ten now i took
five milligrams for a while i take 10
milligrams right now okay and i take it
in the morning
well so here's the thing
and maybe i'm guilty of recommending i
used to recommend dha in the morning but
it can be used especially for people
like yourself who the pattern is a
little off it might help push because
dha can sort of antagonize cortisol a
little bit okay and again there's not
huge studies showing this but it's just
a small handful of studies so it makes
sense to try it one of those though and
it makes a difference
yeah so if you can and if that cortisol
is maybe waking you up or causing light
sleep that could be helpful so try to
take that 10 milligrams like with your
evening supplements maybe an hour before
bed
oh that's a good idea
yeah i sleep um
i don't know if you've come across
anybody like this but i wake up awake
every day like i never wake up tired i
wake up i'm super alert ready to go i
don't even need coffee i just love it um
and i'm tired at night and i'm hungry in
the morning and i'm not hungry at night
um
but i don't i also don't need a lot of
sleep like i have had patches of my life
where i'm like
okay i know like five hours is not
really enough but that's like all i'm
sleeping right now and i'm fine i feel
fine but i know from a health
perspective
that this is detrimental um so
is there any
person in the world that can survive on
six i mean i get right now because i'm i
try and get as much sleep as possible i
mean i rarely get eight but seven is
kind of the number for me
um six and a half is
fine seven and a half's great um is
there anyone that can get away with low
sleep and or is sleep always necessary
for the circadian rhythm and for your
hormones to do what it needs to do
through the night and honestly i think
it depends on who you ask i would say
if
think about have an honest evaluation of
your energy and how you feel in the
morning and if you're waking up without
an alarm ready to go
five or seven hours right like i think
that's probably sufficient for you but
if you were like oh yeah i need a nap at
three o'clock and i'm just exhausted
then probably not getting enough sleep
but matthew walker um will tell you that
and he's got a phd he's really into the
brain and preventing alzheimer's and
things like that
that um
not getting less than seven hours is
insufficient for clearing up some of the
metabolic debris in your brain
that naturally builds up throughout the
day and so you have this whole sort of
cleansing sort of like a dishwasher
process going on in your glio lymphatic
system of the brain so if for short
changing sleep then over time we can
build up metabolites that might
predispose us to early onset
neurodegenerative disorders so just be
mindful of that now that doesn't mean
that if you have one night of just five
hours that you're doomed it just means
hey maybe take a nap try to you can bank
your sleep as well so if you know that
you're going to be traveling
hanging out with friends you haven't
seen in two years and you're like we're
going to be parting it up it's like okay
well maybe take an extra nap that day or
try to aim to get more sleep ahead of
time so you can sleep bank yeah that's
helpful you know that made me think of
um so last year i ran the boston
marathon and so i had a garmin for
really just like to know how far i was
going i wasn't using it for too much
more but um but hrv was something that i
was told to track and um just because
it's a it's like a my the functional
doctor at the time said it's a it's sort
of a foolproof way to know how your
body's doing because you can't cheat the
heart rate
and i found that very interesting and
since so many people wear wearables um
as soon as the marathon was over with i
took that thing off like i don't i i
i learned enough to know that when i
drink a little
i get like half the recovery
and i know that um
i know that if i don't then i generally
recover to sort of like i don't know 80
90 100 sometimes
so i just kind of felt like i was doing
fine but um but i also in recent time
have seen how people can um
you know with heart rate variability
track
um also illnesses coming on like it'll
pick it up before you even feel it and
so like i don't know makeup do you wear
a wearable
i do yeah i have a garmin i wear the
watch and then i also wear the aura ring
at night mm-hmm yeah
a little bit yeah it doesn't totally
jive you know i just like the garmin
watch i like to go out hiking and in the
back country so i i do like like it's
it's yeah barometric pressure there's
all these other features to it and then
the steps are kind of nice but the the
hr i don't wear this when i'm sleeping
um because
the the aura ring how they built it is
it's a lower emf device so that yeah
when you're sleeping and all this you
don't have all these non-native
frequencies right in your you know
temple and all that um so yeah the oral
ring is good because that will give you
an average and and you're right like so
many people will tell you gosh my hrv
tanked in fact when i had coveted in
december of 2020 i knew something was
off i didn't think it was coveted at the
time because it was kind of quite mild
but my hrv totally tanked and my heart
rate started to increase so that was a
sign that hey something's sort of wrong
here then i started to call friends that
i was with and turns out they all had it
right so anyway um i think it's a great
thing to re for people to be aware of
for sure yeah
okay well let's um let's get into
fitness because uh again i there's
there's so much information out there
that feels to me like it's very
um
targeted and researched towards
men and i try really hard to find
specific information to women you should
you do share some especially because
your wife is so fit and she you know
practices fasting windows and exercises
and those things so i do hear you talk
about that and i appreciate that um but
it's not the norm to to really know a
lot about women's hormones and
exercising and fasting and so
i mean you can
i think we talked a little bit about we
talked a little bit about fasting but is
there something specific to women
that should be
we should pay attention to
um and also getting more into sort of
exercise um we're talking about i mean i
used to do crossfit all the time i mean
shoot i used to do two a day workouts i
used to do
all kinds of stuff and so i wonder if
part of that was some of the sort of
like depletion of of the body but um
but just you know the difference between
walking and lifting and high intensity
exercise interval training versus steady
state you know
is there any difference with women that
we should be doing that are different
from men it's an it's an awesome
question you know i do think that women
should vary their intensity based upon
where they are in their cycle and things
like that so
um you know during during the ludial
phase maybe maybe change it up decrease
the intensity a little bit um
you know and listen to the body and not
try to push things too too intensely but
the biggest mistake that that i've seen
working with women since 2006 is
um over exercise and under eating so i
think it's really important for
women to not rely upon cardio as the
primary mechanism to stay lean or burn
fat and instead
you know
use cardio as a sort of the appetizer
the last resort so try to um you know
find out your calorie maintenance look
at your lean body mass you can work with
a coach or someone like that to figure
out how many calories does sally smith
need in a day to preserve lean muscle
mass so reframing it instead of i gotta
burn fat okay how can i maintain this
muscle mass and as a sort of side
benefit of that i will lose the fat i
think that's sort of the biggest
framework shift that a lot of women um
from just a set of heuristics should
refocus on because again it's all this
sort of diet culture you got to cut your
calories you got to eat iceberg lettuce
and carrots and celery for lunch like no
no you should be having red meat and
steak and
you know prioritizing protein to
preserve the lean mass
and then as a side benefit of that you
know when you're at rest you'll just
burn more fat so
that's what i would look at um there's a
friend of mine robert sykes he just
wrote a book on ketogenic bodybuilding
and you know his whole how he helps a
lot of women actually is have them
reverse diet um when they
a lot of women have a lot of people in
general but more women than men i would
say uh have done chronic dieting whether
it's calorie cutting this diet fasting
whatever
but reverse dieting can actually help
you
increase your metabolic rate and sort of
overcome some of the
adaptations that happen
as a side effect of continuously dieting
so let's just say you and i both go on a
diet we lose 10 pounds our resting
metabolic rate has decreased so
we're going to have to continue to con
under consume food to just maintain that
same
sort of metabolic rate and so
you imagine doing this for 10 15 years
off and on off and on
some people are still gaining weight if
they're eating like 900 calories a day
so you're like well how do you keep
cutting calories from that standpoint so
you know reverse dieting or taking the
weekends off and not being afraid
of you know having say
one gram of protein per pound of of lean
body mass you know and and trying to
you know actually start to eat food
again um i think that is problematic is
under eating and over exercise
well what's the rhythm of the reverse
dieting then being basically that you're
in at least a maintenance or a surplus
is that what you're referring to when
you say reverse dieting yeah yeah so
going maybe like a four week block of
where
you know you're you're increa slowly
increasing the calories to a maintenance
phase uh and that way you're increasing
your metabolic rate slowly over time and
this isn't a massive sort of shift
and allowing you to sort of cut back on
the cardio because again a lot of people
are dependent upon cardio so that they
don't gain weight like i have to go run
an hour a day or whatever else i'm going
to get fat well it's like well what you
could actually reverse diet and slowly
increase your resting metabolic rate uh
and while scaling back some of that
cardio to get to a maintenance phase and
replacing it with lifting to increase
your lean muscle mass so that you burn
more calories at rest
exactly and instead of yeah heavily
relying upon the excessive cardio then
focus on okay i need to hit every major
muscle group at least one day per week
whether that's a three-day split a
four-day split but focusing on
getting some taking some of that
intensity and volume and transferring
that to resistance training can be
helpful and
what about
because the like a whole month split i'm
thinking to myself okay if i was gonna
do that where i actually don't do cardio
i just walk um i don't know if that
counts as cardio but i i walk i don't
really run other than after boston last
year i was like bye bye running and i'm
i like i always enjoyed running um but
so i mean i'm trying to think of a month
that i would want to essentially gain
weight and by eating more and you know
burning less calories and and putting on
muscle i can't think of like a whole
month where i'm like oh i don't have
anything to do where i'm not going to be
on camera or not going to be doing
something
is that the only way or can you do more
of a micro sort of
um
split where it's like five on two off
like you know your weekends are
more calorically dense and then during
the week i mean is that gonna is that is
that an option to be able to get
metabolism up
totally an option yeah people um there's
many studies on this they call it like a
5-2 sort of diet plan where yeah really
clean maybe in a slight deficit monday
through friday yeah and saturday and
sunday you're having family over you're
going out with your friends you can be
now it doesn't mean you have candy bars
every hour but it means that you you're
a little bit loose it's more a little
bit higher calorie days and
and so anyway the point here is a little
bit of undulation or variability if
we're too strict for too long
dieting and cardio and high volume
crossfit or whatever it's just a recipe
to burn yourself out and actually cause
loss of muscle mass and slow down your
metabolic rate which ultimately doesn't
help you because you know you naturally
lose muscle as you age it's harder to
put it on totally and and you know i i'm
thinking of just you know i'm i just
turned 40 and you know i've got friends
that are that age or older and you know
there's some that are like if i eat more
than like once or twice a day like i
just gained weight and i just can't even
fathom it i'm like i will i just i'm i
just don't agr i just can't do it i
won't do it i don't believe that's the
way my body should work i believe i
should be able to eat three to four
times a day within a sort of eight to
twelve hour window and i should be fine
like that should not be too much
and um so if that's what someone's doing
because that's all that will work for
them or like even maybe say maybe
they're just people out there that are
just crushing adderall and you know like
not eating all day i don't know um but
you know what are the repercussions of
that and then what's the what's the
comeback from that because if that's all
that they can do
that i don't know if that's really
sustainable so what does that look like
to come back from that kind of um
treatment to your body for an extended
period of time
yeah well again it's more psychological
in the sense that there's resistance to
actually start to eat more calories
uh people think that they're going to
gain a lot more weight than they
actually do
and so yeah you might initially retain
some water the skill might fluctuate but
your body composition especially if
you're exercising
shouldn't change
so much so maybe let's just say you know
if someone were to track what they were
like this is a great way just like a
dietary recall you know you mentioned
that person who like oh my gosh if i eat
more than 900 calories i gain fat okay
well make sure that that's what you're
really consuming 900 calories then let's
start to crank it up and maybe you bump
it up to
250 or 500 calories a day you know
monday through friday
and just kind of see how that goes while
you're still exercising but you know
some people might notice hey i can
actually i feel better i move you know
my muscles feel
just more energy more mental clarity i
don't feel that fatigue and i actually
didn't gain the fat that i thought i
would um so i think that's that's really
an important you know aspect because
here here's what what happens your our
metabolic rate is constantly it's really
influenced by and adapting to how much
energy we're consuming so if we continue
to die it down in fact there was this
biggest loser remember that tv show
biggest loser they did a follow-up study
of these people so they lost a lot of
weight very quickly through a
combination of high volume exercise and
excessive calorie restriction well it
turns out that their resting metabolic
rate was suppressed for over seven years
even though a lot of them continued to
gain weight
after the biggest loser so check it out
yeah their rmrs lower yet they've
regained like about 50 of the weight
that they lost so
they're
you know basically they're in the red
which is not good metabolically speaking
so
and the point is we shouldn't have to
rely upon super high volume exercise and
excessive calorie restriction we should
be able to
con you know not starve ourselves
focus on resistance training and get to
a place where we're like you danica
we're we're walking like hey look we're
taking a leisurely walk we enjoy it the
dogs like it it's good for the family
what have you yeah
okay um
before i before we get into some hit
lists at the end i wanna to
ask about
just certain testing that may be
recommended for people
um
short story i
had my breast implants removed three
weeks ago
for years no matter what i did it didn't
change my body at all i kept gaining
weight all kinds of other side effects
and i remember having a suspicion
years ago in like 2018 like four years
ago
that maybe my hormones are off
so
i'm just telling that quick short story
to say that
what kind of testing should we do
because there are just
there are just things that can hold us
back from the goals that we have and
what i found myself in was this
impossible paradigm of
i'm gaining weight but if i
eat less and work out more i'm now
stressing my body and it's continuing to
go into hibernation and not work
properly
and nothing is really working but if i
don't do the working out and the eating
and then i just keep getting it's just i
felt i found myself in this horrible
situation and so i think that this can
happen it can strike it at different
ages i mean i discovered that every
thyroid was low hypoglycemia all my
hormones were low
heavy metal toxicity so many different
things and so it was an enlightening
year um
but it explained why someone who's you
know i'm by no means you but
uh but i i mean i wrote a book talking
about you know how to work out and how
it works and you know it worked for me
in certain diets and ways to eat and
i couldn't make it happen for myself
anymore and so
what would you recommend for people to
do
test wise to check their body so that
they don't find themselves hitting their
head against a wall of a problem that
they can't get beyond because there are
mechanisms that do
hold us back from these goals
totally
it's a phenomenal question um the basic
labs that i recommend and this would
pick it up too potentially with in your
situation the liver enzyme so let's just
back up so when you go to your doctor
and just get a standard test
i'm not
my website but i have a cheat sheet on
my website intensityhealth.com if you
want to check it out
it's a comprehensive metabolic panel
called a chem24 and cbc so cbc stands
for complete blood count very basic
stuff but there's a few tests on there
that for whatever reason some big
primary care you know kaisers and this
and that they ignore
but you should make sure to request them
so there's three liver tests the ggt ast
alt usually for whatever reason most
labs and doctors just run ast and but
you need all three so in your case if
there is environmental toxins or leakage
from breast implants or what have you
occupational exposure to lead or arsenic
or whatever the ggt and alt again these
are part of the liver function test
enzymes they start to increase above 30.
not in everyone but in some people so
that could be an indicator of
okay well look i've done the calorie
restriction and the exercise something's
not really working here
could it be persistent organic
pollutants could it be the endocrine
disrupting chemicals could it be fatty
liver from you know hyper palatable junk
food all that that's really important
the hemoglobin a1c glucose and
triglycerides and i like to
help people and you know train them like
when you're thinking about lab tests
don't just look at one marker look at
this in a cluster so
what are the triglycerides what do those
look like and so for some people in the
situation that you mentioned
metabolically inflexible can't burn the
fat oftentimes the triglycerides start
to increase they're over a hundred
usually
and that is also linked with an
elevation in sort of a a constellation
that appears to be pre-diabetic so
hemoglobin a1c glucose triglycerides
tend to pair together so those are
things that i would look at and also
look at insulin to see so most doctors
don't think to run insulin but it should
be run and it should never be elevated
in a fasted state because insulin
shouldn't be elevated when you're
fasting it's it's a post-meal hormone um
so that's those are just again like five
or six things that we mentioned yeah
common you can get them at any
commercial lab or major hospital in the
u.s
most often times they're ignored or not
looked at and then you can go down the
chain further and and look at other you
know sort of metabolic tests ldl
ldh there's a few things but you know
just off the cuff just think about
without having to get into boutique labs
from say genova or metametrics or these
companies um those are pretty helpful
and can give you an indicator
about what's going on and
and to go deeper
totally right because it's like phase
one as do these things check out now
phase two is you know let's get into the
boutique labs and let's go let's go
deeper how often would you recommend
that people do that
and what age should they start at
i think in people's 30s so that they
have a good baseline yeah you know i
don't know what good is
totally yeah i mean i was just fortunate
enough that i started when i was in my
20s because i had mentors that told me
to do this but then you can sort of see
changes right like if you see for
example you have your albumin if that
suddenly changed that's sort of a a red
flag that there could be some sort of
tumor processes going on or
maybe a pre-cancer situation so anyway
it's good to have these things you don't
need to some people test every month way
too much i mean unless you're actively
you know figuring out some complex you
know just had a heart attack for example
um but i think once a year every 18
months it's a good idea
okay that's good all right what are some
top supplements i i first off maybe i'll
ask do you think that it's possible that
we can get everything that we need from
our diet or are we in
a state
now where
based on soils
food manufacturing and sourcing that we
actually can't achieve the um
the the level of
vitamins and nutrients that we need for
ultimate health
can we get it through food or should and
then if not then what supplements are
the most important and maybe just the
most important supplements anyway
because you probably have to be pretty
determined to get all your nutrients in
if you wanted to do it through food
yeah you know i think there's probably
like two percent of the population who
have like a you know homestead with cows
and chickens and you know grass-fed so
jealous
yeah biodynamic farming like if that's
you then probably you don't need to
spend any money on supplements um but
you know most people can benefit from
taking vitamin d especially believe it
or not even in arizona there was one
study in tucson arizona it's really
sunny as many people know in tucson and
uh
this was a college kids and this was
like from 2007 were surveyed and
analyzed and looked look at their labs
they had insufficient vitamin d because
we're taught now
that the sun is bad that's going to
cause skin cancer that it's really you
got to cover up and so people are
outside but they're covering up their
skin and they're wearing sunscreen so
most people deficient in vitamin d
an easy one that's affordable is iodine
iodine is very important if you don't
have a water filter or drink filtered
water you're getting probably chlorine
and fluoride in your water both of which
antagonize iodine as you know iodine
very important for the thyroid but
women concentrate iodine in their breast
tissue and in the uterus so there's
really good data showing it's helpful
for new moms iodine is they must
consider this because iodine deficiency
is linked with suboptimal iq and
developing babies so
iodine and it's so cheap i don't even
know why
little drops yeah you know it's on
amazon you can find it anywhere
recommended
is
um so it's in usually micrograms so like
one drop would be 150 micrograms i want
to say the rda is maybe 400 micrograms
which is far too low
most people that
in japan and other parts of the world
that eat seafood would get like two to
three to up to 12 milligrams so you can
be pretty liberal with the dosaging um
yeah so i you know in our household we
have some droppers you know we'll take
like a milligram one to two milligrams
every day so
um but yeah i9 is a big one let's see
what else um i'm a huge fan of magnesium
for obvious reasons uh it's a
participant in over 350 enzymatic
reactions in the body so magnesium's
really helpful you want to look for
glycinate or malate or threonate those
are the forms that are going to be best
absorbed
again these are all affordable most
people can afford everything that we
talked about
now for women that have issues with pcos
or sleep stress issues
l-theanine and inositol can be helpful
um before bed in the evening so those
are things to consider more specialty
sort of micronutrients but not not
egregious or not super outrageous in
terms of price um
gosh what else i mean i'm biased i
created an electrolyte that's really
really cool we have real salt and all
these things so electrolyte can be
helpful in and also i should say
creatine for women
very helpful in fact most research has
been on creatine for men but women don't
store as much creatine as men it can
really help them
from the communications asking my doctor
about this i was like should i take
creatine and i think the idea with from
from a female perspective if i'm going
to speak for the collective is that
you're going to have water retention
you're going to like it's going to bloat
you
um but that's not true
so yeah here's the thing danica you know
all the creatine stuff you have the
perception of what bloating of water
retention all that that was from you
know bad actors in the late 90s that
sold creatine with
four parts dextrose to one part creatine
so let's say you take five grams of
creatine you would be taking 20 plus
grams sometimes 40 grams of pure sugar
so then people would retain water they'd
have kidney issues like whoa man why is
this creatine cut no it wasn't the
creatine it was the refined sugar that
was paired with it because there was
this perception that you had to have
sugar in order to make creatine more
effective but new research actually
shows that electrolytes like salt
calcium potassium magnesium help make
creatine
function better and help with creatine
is also involved in osmolysis and
functioning of hydration but
it really functions when you're
exercising it helps the cell uh with
energy production so that's how it works
it's not anabolic uh people think oh
creatine i'm gonna get facial hair if
i'm a woman no it does not impact
testosterone or any of the androgens
it's solely functioning on this at the
cellular level at hydration and also
helping with exercise uh energy
production so yeah that's a big one
especially for women who have been vegan
or vegetarian or don't eat red meat they
stand to benefit the most from
supplementing with creatine yeah and you
take that right before you work out is
that a pre-workout or is it a morning
thing
yeah i mean anytime you remember but
researchers have looked at pre-workout
and intra workout like during the
workout you could just sip on it
i wasn't gonna ask this i was gonna try
and wrap it up but i ha i feel like you
mentioned it um and it made me it was
something i was thinking about
today vegans and vegetarians
is it possible to sustain that and be
healthy healthy and get everything that
you need
uh with that diet because i feel like
that's one of those that man people
might try it for a little bit they might
feel okay for a second but
i mean i don't i don't think there's
anyone i've ever met that hasn't said
yeah i i got i was the worst i was the
least least healthy i'd ever been
things like that
is this just like because it's a it's
thing like vegan restaurants and you
know i don't know call the shows that
come out propaganda i don't know maybe
they're maybe they are maybe they're not
but it's very popular
it is yeah i mean everywhere you go it's
plant-based i tried powered by plants oh
man i tried i was like uh i mean and i i
then i've kind of migrated towards fish
and now i eat it all because i truly
feel the best with high-fat animal meat
yeah
me as well and so i've dabbled and
experimented with all this you know we
have a lot of
like 400 square feet of gardening space
and so for the month of july and august
you know we
every year we try to eat as many
vegetables as we can and i was just
honest with myself i'm like you know
what i have a lot of gastrointestinal
distress i feel bloated
i feel like i just look sort of
emaciated in the face i'm not as strong
so i just i'm like you know what and
this is just my end of one i'm sure
there are some people who
um do well in it but what i found
generally speaking is most people
gravitate after they've been vegan or
vegetarian to having more fish and
having red meat because they're either
anemic they're deficient you know in
iron and as consequence they're anemic
or they have other b vitamin
insufficiencies because of say the
cofactors
all the like we talked about creatine
you're not going to find creatine in
plants you're not going to find other
carno nutrients like carnosine like
taurine taurine is highly concentrated
in the heart it does a lot of great
things it's a natural electrolyte as
well you're not going to find much zinc
in plants you're not going to find
thiamin or b12 so their choline there
are so many micronutrients
that you're not going to find in plants
so
i think people again we need to be
really honest about
why
are we being plant-based because again
we're hearing messaging from the powers
that be that eating meat's not
sustainable eating meat rots or colon
eating meat creates heart disease i mean
there's all these things you're
destroying the planet if you consume
animal products but
there's a big difference in the quality
and the amount of environmental
destruction of say you know
conventionally agricultural raised
industrial agriculture pork versus say
you know grass-fed free-range pasture
beef right so total different where you
have a cat an animal living in its
native environment eating food that it
should be eating and then regenerating
the agriculture versus something that's
on a commercial feed lot that's creating
tons of sewage and waste and antibiotics
right so we need to sort of disentangle
and be a little bit more nuanced about
the types of foods that we're eating and
so on
and likewise when it comes to a
plant-based diet a lot of people you
know have plant-based junk food right
it's like oh it's plant-based it's just
soy protein canola oil and sugar yeah
that's derived from plants but that is
not nourishing your body that is
creating inflammation you can look at
any of the animal any of the studies
that have been done
looking at creating metabolic
endotoxemia and gut dysbiosis and
altering the gut biome
you know right you can have vegan drunk
food and it's going to do that so
again most people when they go
plant-based they're not eating
organic vegetables it's plant-based junk
food so
not good but to answer your question
specifically could you do it if you're
on a hawaiian island
growing your own stuff right you had all
sorts of mangoes papayas avocados
coconuts and maybe you had some fish
periodically you could probably pull it
off but most people are not doing that
so i think we just need to be a little
bit honest with ourselves and um and i
don't think there's anything wrong with
having red meat and fish supplementing a
plant-based diet with that periodically
because you're getting nutrients that
you wouldn't be getting from plants yeah
all right there's so many other
questions but i know we probably need to
wrap it up so okay based on i was asking
jen my producer just from like what's a
good question and so i think this is a
question that honestly applies to like
everybody but
maybe especially girls um okay so if you
had sort of like a very short amount of
time and something that you were
preparing for and honestly maybe this
fits in really well with kind of cycling
and having those ebbs and flows of diet
of caloric restriction but then
then somewhat of a surplus or
maintenance calorie amount so
what can you do if you have just a
couple of weeks before an event or a
trip
what can you do to lean out before
before that i would recommend either
alternate day fasting
or alternate day omad which is one meal
a day so that would be an easy way and
again i like the alternating
because you're not chronically
suppressing because when we chronically
cut calories even for three weeks we get
this metabolic adaptation slowing of the
metabolic rate so you have a wedding
coming up you're like okay how do i like
what do i do you could eat your normal
diet monday tuesday you're having just
one meal let's say it's lunch
and maybe it's it's less less overall
calories maybe you cut your calories by
500 or you know 750 right then you could
eat normal on wednesday back to the one
meal a day or or really low calorie on
thursday and so on so that's what i
would suggest but on those days where
you're eating normally i would really
try to exercise and focus on
weightlifting not cardio so trying to
hit those muscles yeah because that's
actually going to help prevent the sort
of metabolic adaptation slowing of the
metabolic rate
and it will help you burn fat and look
more fit i mean here's the thing
even if you look at natural bodybuilders
who go
they're skinny they have they have no
muscle because they they dye it down um
you don't have to lose as much fat to
look good if you have muscle underneath
and so that's the thing that i would
focus on
of course you could bake in cardio into
that but i would do more intervals so
instead of hopping on the elliptical i
would say hit the skierg hit the concept
row
focus on power like you know try to row
200 meters in
under a minute or something like really
try to go intense for 45 seconds or 60
seconds and then take a break and come
back to it
that's what i would focus on but i do
like the alternate day like you know
i'll periodically do that if i'm gonna
go on to hawaii we went to hawaii in
march i was like okay so um every other
day i was doing a really low calorie day
but i wasn't
it wasn't consistently low and so i
never like got that permanent sort of uh
suppression in my metabolic rate what
about like uh what about the macro
balance of it is there anything you do
with that
yeah i mean i would cut out all the
refined stuff or only have that on like
one day a week so no ice cream no
cookies no bread no pasta and i would
have my carbs early in the day so before
noon
early
okay all right so you can have it say
before you train so that could be either
right before like within a few hours of
exercise or after and then have then
just keep it protein and fat and that
for most people yeah you're gonna see a
sh
the the the biggest thing how you know
if you're making progress is how do your
pants feel that's the first thing that
should change is around the the
waistline
and so that should start to change and
what's cool about what we just talked
about is you could probably sustain that
too if you wanted to like as a strategy
long term
and not have a lot of
weight regain you know
whereas what people would normally do is
say oh my gosh i got this wedding coming
up i'm gonna have iceberg lettuce and
celery and just do a bunch of cardio
every day
you're gonna gain a bunch of weight once
that ends and that's not good amazing
thank you so much you're just such a
wealth of information
we're going to have to do this again
because i think i probably have like 15
more questions
yeah anytime happy to do so thank you so
much thanks everybody for listening to
the pretty intense podcast today i hope
you enjoyed it if you like what you
heard today and you want to hear more
please click on the subscribe button